my job is actually 24 hours a day to
take care of my hands I'm definitely
very cautious with my hands I'm mark
careful more delicate with my movements
I get manicures fairly frequently
I don't do myself my name is Ellen
Surratt Susan Schell Tom Nico and I am a
hand model
I got noticed as a hand model after I
was featured in a jewelry shoot for a
magazine at the jewelry company I was
working at one day I was on a commercial
shooting essential park and they picked
me to do all the hand shots because the
hand model never showed up probably most
of us fall into it by action I'm always
in these upside-down positions and
having to have the director on top of me
or underneath me you're being asked to
do the most natural things in the most
unnatural ways sometimes I am in weird
positions for my oddest hand shoot I had
to pretend to chop a live human placenta
I had to do this one thing where I had
to be on Howard Stern's kind of naked
body he says to me look we're going to
try something different I want you to
stick your thumb in the girl's mouth
I've been a hand model around 19 years
it's been great I've been very lucky I
feel like I'm gonna do this Psalm 90 my
hands are gonna look great and I love
doing it and you always need a hand that
looks really good
you